it's very different from the first film
it's got basically more of everything
the Harry Potter franchise is absolutely
legendary we wanted to get into
everything that went into what brought
the world of Hogwarts to life there are
some incredible practical effects did
you know the Weasley kitchen really
cleans itself as well as some stunning
locations that really made the visuals
pop off the screen let's get into it
number one where Harry gets to speak in
his iconic serpent tongue in the book
instead of a metal door this entrance is
described as a wall that is decorated by
two entwined snakes when Harry speaks in
parcel tongue the snake's part in the
wall opens in the movie we get a giant
round metal door with seven snakes that
fold in on themselves as the Nath snake
slithers around the door opening it
definitely not the door for someone with
a fear of reptiles you'd also think that
be all CGI but it was actually all
practical mark olamore the special
effects supervising engineer created the
door to actually open that way he was
also responsible for creating the locks
and doors on the vaults in Gringotts
bank number two this one might actually
surprise you when Ron Fred and George
rescue Harry from The dursleys this is
the first time we get to see the inside
of the Weasley home Harry is in awe at
The Charmed objects being able to
complete their own tasks like dishes
cleaning themselves knives chopping
vegetables knitting needles making
garments those were all mechanical props
moving in real time created by the
special effects team they even recreated
these moving props for people to see
during the Warner Brothers Studio Tour
so technically you could have your own
self-cleaning kitchen if you wanted
number three more particularly the
Divinity School built in the 15th
century and strictly used as a room
where lectures and exams were held it's
undergone a significant transition it's
now only used for ceremonies events and
tours the this room is used in the
Chamber of Secrets as the hospital Wing
where they used to house the Petrified
students with Hermione unfortunately
being one of them number four better
known as the Hogwarts Express Bridge we
get a great view of it when Harry and
Ron are on their way back to Hogwarts in
the Weasleys flying forward the Glenn
Finn and Viaduct is a railway viaduct in
Scotland built from 1897 to 1901. it's
the longest concrete Railway Bridge in
Scotland at 380 meters number five a
Forbidden Forest yet they're always
going in the first film they utilized
black Park and Ivor a 560 acre Reserve
but when it came to Chamber of Secrets
they filmed entirely in the Warner
Brothers Studio because they needed to
create aragog's Lair you can visit the
Forbidden Forest on the studio tour it
houses about 19 trees that are over 12
feet in diameter have you been number
six let's talk about the dursley house
if you see in our other video about the
Philosopher's Stone you would know they
originally used the actual Suburban
house as the set for the dursley home
the owners ended up selling that home
later and were sure pretty profit was
turned so this time the old house got a
major upgrade to one of the biggest
studios in the world at least the
exterior anyway leaveston Studios was
bought by Warner Brothers and is
considered the ultimate Film Production
facility built by filmmakers for
filmmakers you'd never know how many
scenes took place on these incredible
backlots
number seven located in the village of
lakic the Abbey was found in the early
13th century it was a nunnery until it
was sold in the 18th century and was
then converted into a residence it was
used for several interior Hogwarts
scenes one in particular was in the
Chamber of Secrets after Harry leaves
Professor Lockhart's classroom and
here's the Basilisk For the First Time
The Abbey was also featured in Fantastic
Beasts the crimes of Grindelwald number
eight an absolute stunning Mountainside
scenery in Scotland Glencoe served as a
set in several of the Harry Potter
movies it makes sense given the unique
dramatic atmosphere it puts off you
might recognize it as the backdrop of
Hagrid's Hut the turreted Gatehouse of
Hogwarts and the Hogwarts Bridge number
nine the oldest film studio in the world
named after the London borough of its
origin this studio has been the center
of its British film industry since 1902.
that's a hundred years before chamber of
Secrets even premiered one of the first
on-screen versions of Hamlet was created
there in 1910. since then the cameras
have been non-stop tons of iconic BBC TV
shows of the 60s 70s and 80s were
produced at e-link Studios some names
you might recognize are Doctor Who and
Monty Python it seems like every set and
location used in Harry Potter is full of
incredible history
number 10 here comes the part where we
talk about platform nine and three
quarters in the movies platform nine and
three quarters is located between
Platform 9 and 10 but in real life those
platforms are separated by tracks they
actually use platforms four and five for
filming if you visit the station today
you can visit their own rendition of
platform nine and three quarters as well
as a Harry Potter shop JK Rowling chose
King's cross for the films because it
holds some personal magic for her it's
where her parents first met number 11
stepping outside after Ron and Terry
missed their train we get a wonderful
establishing shot of the magical Saint
pancreas station though yes King's cross
station was used for the inside shots
Saint Pancras was used for the outside
the station first opened in 1868 and is
one of the great achievements of early
Victorian engineering with its stunning
Victorian Gothic architecture it remains
one of the world's most elegant stations
to this day number 12 how can we forget
dead she'll pay for that one Malfoy eat
slugs at least Ryan gets to throw up
slugs in front of a Scenic church this
scene was one of the many shots at
Durham Cathedral you can visit the
cathedral's chapter house and you can
step inside Professor mcgonagall's
classroom where the students
transfigured goblets into rats number
13. a lot goes down on the staircase you
might remember these iconic Steps From
the first film when all of the first
year students walk in to meet Professor
McGonagall but they were also used in
the Chamber of Secrets when Harry and
Ron show up late to Hogwarts as well as
in a flashback scene where we see Tom
Riddle having a conversation with
Dumbledore Christ Church is a working
school as well as a religious
institution but with the purchase of one
ticket you can climb up these steps in
real life
number 14 also known as the school of
Hogwarts A Beautiful historic castle
with over 950 years of History owned by
the Percy family the castle remains a
family home to this day for the 12th
Duke and Duchess and their children also
this strange piece of Architecture is no
stranger to the media not only serving
as Hogwarts in both the first and second
Harry Potter movies but it's also been
used in Downton Abbey Transformers the
last night and many many others
number 15 anik Castle may have had the
exterior shots taken care of but
Gloucester cathedral was the star of
Hogwarts corridors while filming the
movie they had to make sure all light
switches and electrical outlets were
covered up to look like Stone they also
had to cover up the Halos on the stained
glass because they didn't want anyone to
think it was actually being shot inside
a church as well as the hundreds of
tombstones on The Cloister floors Harry
Potter is chock full of incredible
locations throughout England and
Scotland immersive set design on the
backlots of Warner Brothers Studios and
Charming churches and train stations
that hold more history than an entire
semester of school could cover what was
your favorite set piece in the film